an abstract artist wants to create two
proportional triangular paintings the
dimensions of one painting are shown and
that's this top one right over here how
long should the two missing sides be in
the second painting so there are two
proportional triangular paintings or one
way to think about it's gonna be two
triangles that are similar and actually
we know based on how these triangles are
marked up that they are similar
triangles you have this angle this angle
with these two arcs right over here it
has the same measure as that angle right
over there this angle with the three
arcs has the same measures this angle
right over there and that this angle let
me do it in a new color
with the one arc has the same measure as
this angle right over there if the if
the corresponding angles are have the
same measure of the corresponding angles
are congruent then we know that these
are similar triangles the other thing
that tells you about similar triangles
or if you know that two triangles are
similar that means that the ratio
between corresponding sides is going to
be the same so let's look at the
corresponding sides and then let's try
to figure out that same ratio or use
that same ratio so we can figure out the
missing sides right over here so the
first thing if you look at the side
that's opposite this blue angle this one
arc angle side XY over here that's going
to correspond to the side that's
opposite in this blue angle over here so
side a B these are corresponding sides
you could also view it as a side between
the orange and the magenta the side
between the orange and the magenta
likewise this side right over here
that's opposite the origin go it's
opposite the orange the double arc angle
is going to correspond to this side
that's opposite the orange double arc
angle or you could view it as a side
that's between the magenta and the blue
angle and then finally let me use it we
have this side which is opposite the
magenta angle it's opposite the magenta
angle it's between the blue and the
orange angles is going to correspond to
this side which is opposite the magenta
angle and between the blue and orange
angles so what this tells us is that the
ratio we know since they are similar the
ratio between corresponding sides is
going to be the same so the ratio
between these two sides
a be 2xy the ratio between the length of
side a b and length of side XY is going
to be equal to the ratio between the
length of side BC and the length of side
y z which is going to be equal to the
ratio of AC AC to X Z and they tell us
what some of these lengths are they tell
us a B is equal to 5 they tell us that
XY is equal to 2 they tell us that BC is
equal to 9 and Y Z is one of the things
we're going to have to solve for but
they also tell us that AC is equal to 10
all right no one I want to use the
magenta AC is equal to 10 and we also
have to solve for X C so we can actually
get this you know this triple equality
we can actually create two separate
equations each of which have one unknown
and then we can solve for that unknown
so the first is you have five halves is
equal to 9 over Y Z is equal to 9 9 over
Y Z and to solve for y Z was a bunch of
ways that you could do it but you could
just let's see we can multiply Y Z times
both sides you could multiply Y Z times
both sides Y is e times both sides
actually I won't swell like you come up
to and then we can multiply both sides
by 2/5 but let's just do one step at a
time so then you get Y Z Y Z times five
halves times five halves is equal to 9
is equal to 9 and then you can multiply
both sides times the reciprocal of five
halves so you multiply both sides times
2/5 and we're doing that so that we can
isolate the Y Z and then this right over
here these cancel out on the left hand
side we're left with just Y Z and on the
right hand side we are left with 9 times
2 is 18 over 5 and we can turn that this
is the same thing if we write it as a
mixed number 5 goes into 18 three times
with a remainder of 3 so it's 3 and 3/5
which is the same thing as 3 point 6 so
Y Z over here is going to be 3 point 6
so we've done one on the sides now we
have to figure out what XZ is and so
here we know that five halfs we know
that five halves is going to be equal to
10 over X Z is going to be equal to 10
over X Z and once again we can multiply
there's multiple ways you could do it
you could flip both sides of this
equation so you could say now so I'll do
it in a slightly different way than we
did it that way just just so there's
multiple ways to solve this you could
say 2 over 5 is equal to XZ over 10 so
I'm just taking the reciprocal of both
sides and then multiply both sides of
this equation by 10 multiply both sides
by 10 so you're left with XZ is equal to
10 times 2 is 20 divided by 5 so this is
going to be 4 so X Z ends up being 4
that is 4 and we're done
the smaller painting has dimensions 2
3.6 and 4